o mundo que a gente quer na verdade um
único agente está sonhando e é um pouco
disso que a gente vai vivenciar é esse
convite na verdade foi que a gente possa
experimentar aqui um pouquinho dessa
história mas pra isso pra gente poder
entrar em campo junto é preciso checar
se a gente realmente está pronto para
bater um bolão porque o desafio é muito
grande então quero fazer isso junto com
vocês
a gente chega agora não dá mais pra
esperar ser nesse exato minuto e para
isso elas vão fazer um teste uma prova
para checar se realmente a gente está
pronto para poder entrar em campo junto
e o teste é o seguinte ó poder levantar
as duas mãos levanta bem as duas mãos
pra gente ver bem quem são os jogadores
e jogadoras que estão chegando nesse
grande jogo que vai mudar o mundo e
realizar o mundo que a gente só é porque
o teste é o seguinte ó estica bem os
braços e as mãos porque o teste vem no
formato de um desafio o desafio seguinte
quando desejar
o desafio é colocar os dedos das mãos
dos dedos dos pés
calma calma respiração do estica o braço
calma respira calma pode ser perigoso
já são calma 123 já valendo
ok ok calma calma poderão levantar de
novo a uma relaxa um pouco solta e para
andar de extensão em nada
respira fundo a tensão poderão levantar
novamente a atenção explica bem os
braços esticados bem as mãos atenção
mais uma chance sim
segundo tempo a tensão desafia o mesmo
colocar os dedos das mãos nos dedos dos
pés
mas agora de uma maneira diferente da
primeira vez não pode ser do mesmo jeito
a tensão já
num rock maravilha deu tempo deu tempo a
tensão relaxamos um pouco solta pescoço
assim relaxa sombras poderão levantar
novamente a atenção explica bem os
braços para sinalizar sua presença que
empresa ea gente vai assim descobrindo
se a gente consegue alcançar o ine sim
nesse grande jogo e tem o índice também
então agora prorrogação para que a gente
precisa de um mar mais uma chance e
prorrogação atenção podemos ficar bem os
braços o desafio é o mesmo colocar os
dedos das mãos e dos pés mas agora de
uma maneira diferente e confortável
já o alguém agora do jeito que está
mesmo diferente confortável e
compartilhada não pode ser sozinho
já para vir assim poderemos sentar se
quer que o forcado muito bom
a operação para que em 1992 foi um ano
divisor de águas na minha vida foi
quando conheci os jogos cooperativos
conhecer os jogos cooperativos foi
extremamente revolucionário
especialmente porque me fez perceber a
visão de mundo que eu tinha até aquele
momento era uma visão muito baseada nas
polaridades do símbolo não do certo e do
errado do bom e de ruim do sucesso do
fracasso e muito me diziam que a vida
era um grande jogo e que no grande jogo
da vida eu podia ganhar ou perder e
vencer jogos cooperativos me fez
recordar das minhas experiências na
infância me lembro em situações como
essa de escutar com muita frequência mas
rodolpho
você precisa aprender a perder
aqui era muito incômodo para mim mas eu
segui em frente né
e aí mas virava e mexia escutava de novo
mas rodolpho
você precisa aprender a perder cara
porque perder é parte da vida e ganhar é
pra poucos
o fato é que eu fui convivendo com
aquela experiência convivendo com aquela
crença durante muito tempo achando que
aquilo era natural
até que depois de muitos e muitos anos
eu fui convidado a jogar de novo aquele
mesmo jogo e tínhamos muitos tinham
muitas pessoas mas ali tinha alguma
coisa diferente
era também mais confortável e ainda era
compartilhada
o jogo era mesmo a música tocou as
pessoas começaram a dançar
logo a música parou todo mundo sentou
daqui a pouco levantar ou retirar as
cadeiras mas as pessoas não ninguém sair
daquele jogo ninguém é excluído o
desafio era pra todos
curiosamente quanto mais faltavam
recursos mais aumentava ajuda o cuidado
com o outro a solidaridade e junto vinha
também a alegria a celebração e
fundamentalmente a cooperação e para o
meu espanto
eu vivi algo inacreditável ao final
estávamos todos sentados em uma única
cadeira aquilo pra mim me jogou num
universo de inquietações especialmente
me fez refletir sobre os meus
aprendizados do passado lembra aprender
perder ali eu pude perceber que eu podia
sim realizar objetivos sonhos e idéias e
que para isso não era necessário que
alguém não realizasse que alguém não
chegasse onde estava desejando chegar
especialmente também me fez sentir o
sabor da cooperação e de como aquele
ambiente podia no trio
profundamente a minha experiência na
terra ali eu podia ser o mesmo e não
precisava ficar correndo em busca de
alguma coisa externa um padrão que
estava fora que não era eu
assim foi também tão forte e foi
inevitável também queremos juntar com os
meus amigos e amigas para poder
continuar jogando daquele jeito e assim
seguimos durante muitos e muitos anos
jogando criando transformando e
compartilhando para manter vivo aquele
lugar
de lá pra cá a rede da cooperação foi
crescendo exponencialmente e muitas
pessoas passaram a se conectar a partir
de uma nova cultura de um novo jeito de
ver e viver a vida
milhões de pessoas passaram a conhecer
jogos cooperativos no brasil ea praticar
a cooperação no seu dia-a-dia escolas
públicas e privadas passaram a adotar
pedagogia da cooperação nas suas
atividades robustos programas sociais
baseadas na estrutura dos jogos
cooperativos começaram a aparecer fortes
movimentos de cooperação nas
organizações pequenas empresas grandes
multinacionais começaram a viver isso
mais intensamente no ambiente acadêmico
ganhou status de cursos de pós graduação
que se espalharam por diversas capitais
brasileiras e com isso começamos a ter
produções científicas livros artigos
dissertações de mestrado teses de
doutorado fundamentando toda essa
experiência e também foi reconhecida
como uma por uma doutora da unesp como
uma das principais abordagens e
tendências da educação física brasileira
o fato é que esse movimento no brasil
começou a crescer e ganhar uma dimensão
muito grande e chama a atenção de
pessoas não só aqui mas também no
exterior até que eu tive uma primeira
experiência fora do brasil que aconteceu
na holanda
aline holanda eu pude perceber a força
eo poder dos jogos
instâncias da música sustentados pela
cooperação como processos pedagógicos
ali eu pude mais uma vez assim entrar em
uma inquietação numa reflexão um pouco
mais profunda que era eu já sabia que a
cooperação era capaz de provocar
mudanças nos paradigmas nos padrões mas
aqui exatamente ela estava servindo à
que servia a cooperação nesse momento eu
percebi um forte movimento em mim e aí
também perceber um movimento de querer
reconhecer isso no mundo
me coloquei à serviço de pessoas que
vinham realizando projetos de alto
impacto social e assim seguindo uma
jornada pelo mundo afora
foram oito iniciativas em oito países
durante oito meses foram 14
empreendedores assistidos nos seus
respectivos projetos foram quase mil
pessoas impactadas diretamente por esse
simples movimento foram seis comunidades
atendidas cinco organizações e dois
órgãos do governo
quatro universidades e uma escola formal
foram 33 ações em diversos formatos e
mais de 10 abordagens e metodologias
colaborativas difundidos por onde eu
passei isso começou a chamar muita
atenção e passei a receber convites para
mais dois ciclos de oito iniciativas em
oito países durante oito meses
mas foi quando voltei para o brasil
depois de tanto tempo viajando depois de
tanto tempo conhecendo pessoas histórias
incríveis comunidades maravilhosas que
eu tive o meu maior presente
foi quando se pôde sentar na mesa para
comer o nosso arroz zinho com feijão
gente que é um exemplo o feijão
e depois de sobremesa como o nosso
brigadeiro cara brigadeiro é tudo de bom
ali eu pude reconhecer a minha família o
meu time
a minha história de onde eu vim quem eu
era
as pessoas que eu amo os meus amigos e
minhas amigas
ali eu pude reconhecer um pouquinho das
belezas e riquezas da nossa gente da
nossa cultura da nossa história porque
foi capaz também de reconhecer belezas e
riquezas de tantas comunidades de
pessoas histórias incríveis por onde eu
tive a oportunidade de passar tão
diferentes das nossas
e justamente tão especiais por isso
porque foi na diferença e em cooperação
que eu pude reconhecer a mim mesmo
foi também quando eu voltei eu tive uma
conversa com minha mãe e eu me recordava
de uma bate papo que tive que a gente
teve um pouquinho antes das viagens onde
eu dizia para ela que eu não me sentia
pronto para seguir essa jornada
especialmente porque eu não me achava
capaz de me comunicar com as pessoas
plenamente e poder escutá las nas suas
necessidades
eu não sabia eu estava pronto para poder
falar em outros idiomas eu achava que eu
ainda não seria capaz disso
e ela escutou aquilo com muita atenção
muita paciência mãe né
aí num determinado momento ele estava
falando tanto que ela falou assim filho
cama brincar um pouquinho
olha quando você nasceu
você não sabia falar português
saber falar inglês sabia falar espanhol
não sabia falar nada disso ea gente
compreendia muito bem aquilo que você
queria comunicar para nós e mais você
também podia compreender muito bem
aquele que aquilo que a gente queria te
dizer você está pronto sim não precisa
esperar mais nada não dessa linguagem
que eu tô falando filho você conhece
muito bem
eu tenho certeza que nesse caminho que
você decidiu trilhar
você vai encontrar pessoas que também
conhecem muito bem
você tem toda a minha bênção você pode
em paz
e assim eu me enche de coragem e assim
eu seguir nessa jornada pelo mundo afora
e assim também o contínuo e da mesma
maneira chega até aqui como a maior
descoberta desse mundo de que jogos
cooperativos de que a cooperação são
meios e instrumentos poderosíssimos
capazes de criar ambientes que nos
permitem acessar aquilo que é presente
em todos os seres humanos em qualquer
lugar deste planeta ambientes capazes de
nos lembrar daquilo que é presente em
todos nós o amor e que sem o amar que é
o amor em ação um fatalmente deixaremos
de existir porque somos totalmente
dependentes dele
o que eu desejo no fundo é que o mundo
inteiro possa se esse lugar que eu
redescobri dentro de mim porque hoje é
insuportável viver num ambiente onde eu
não sou querido onde não só aceito onde
não sou amado e por isso eu faço o que
eu faço e movimento já para realizar
esse mundo confiando que se por acaso eu
me esquecer
a gente vai se lembrar disso junta
talvez cantando algumas canções que nos
ajudem a fazer isso de forma coletiva
pessoas que nos dizem assim ainda se eu
falasse a língua dos homens se eu
falasse a língua dos anjos
os sem amor eu na taça seria é sou o
amor que conhece o que é ter na tim o
amor é bom não quero mar não sente
inveja
sim vai desce ainda que eu falasse a
língua dos anjos sem amor eu nada seria
a gratidão